This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二，这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中坚韧精神、健身以及培养心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是数字的2%，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利西。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。这需要一大批网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名男同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们在二十几岁时遇到的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。
A quick disclaimer, before we get into it, this episode includes topics around body image, eating disorders and body dysmorphia. Please consider whether you're in the right mental headspace to listen to this today. Feel free to listen to something else and return when the time is right. There are resources in the episode description if you need help or further information. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show or welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here, back for another episode. Well, I feel like the episode title kind of says it all. We're being vulnerable today, guys. And I'm kind of super nervous recording this, but you know what? This show has always been about being honest
一个简短的免责声明，在我们深入探讨之前，本期节目包含有关体象、进食障碍和体相障碍的主题。请考虑一下你今天的心态是否适合收听这个内容。如果你愿意，可以去听听别的，等时机成熟时再回来。如果你需要帮助或进一步的信息，节目简介中会有相关资源。大家好。欢迎回到节目中，或者说欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴有你们在这里，回来收听另一期节目。嗯，我觉得节目标题就已经说明了一切。大家，我们今天要变得脆弱了。录制这个我其实有点超级紧张，但你知道吗？这个节目一直以来都是关于诚实地面对
with the experiences, the thoughts and the feelings of our 20s. And right now, I've been feeling really ugly. I've been feeling unattractive. And it's been really messing with my headspace and my self-perception. So I want to talk about it today because I know it's hard to talk about these things, but I'm guessing there's someone out there who is going to relate and feel less alone, and that's really what matters to me. I guess just like some background. I don't think that I've ever felt particularly beautiful during my life. Like even since I was a kid,
我们二十几岁的经历、想法和感受。而现在，我一直觉得自己真的很丑。我一直觉得自己很不吸引人。这真的把我的心态和自我认知搞得一团糟。所以我今天想谈谈这个，因为我知道谈论这些事情很难，但我猜会有产生共鸣并觉得自己不那么孤单的人存在，这对我来说才是最重要的。我想就当作是一些背景介绍吧。我觉得自己在生活中从来没有觉得自己特别漂亮。就像甚至自我还是个孩子的时候，
I was such a tomboy growing up and I always had self-cut bangs and was a little bit dirty from playing outside. And I guess as I grew up and external image and beautiful. beauty standards really begun to matter, I just never felt that attractive. And my body has never really looked like what I think I've been taught to see as beautiful. My shoulders have always been broad. I've always had big thighs and there are all these other little things that only we tend to notice. And in my teenage years, I think that deficiency or those imperfections mattered so much to me. But as I've grown up, I've adopted what I would call a more mature mindset.
我从小就是个假小子，总是自己剪刘海，因为在外面玩而弄得有点脏。我想随着我长大，外部形象和美丽。审美标准真的开始变得重要，我只是从来没有觉得那么有吸引力。而且我的身材也从来没有长成过我认为被教导的那种美丽的样子。我的肩膀一直很宽。我一直都有粗壮的大腿，还有所有其他只有我们自己倾向于注意到的微小事情。在我的青少年时期，我认为那种缺陷或那些不完美对我来说非常重要。但随着我长大，我采纳了一种我称之为更成熟的心态。
I grew into my body, but also my identity and my personality. And I used confidence as this kind of armor, even when it felt fake. You know, I firmly believe in the mentality that you need to kind of fake it till you make it. And confidence is one of those things that you can definitely fake, but recently those thoughts have really had a resurgence for me. And I've just found myself consumed with and kind of constantly thinking about beauty and whether I'm attractive and what people think of me and everything that is wrong with how I look. And I want to share that experience because it's so nuanced. You know, for the first time in my life, I've been Googling plastic surgery and things I'd never thought I do, like a fucking chin reduction surgery.
我适应了自己的身材，同时也适应了我的身份和个性。我把自信当作一种盔甲，即使它感觉是假的。你知道，我坚信“假装直到你成功”这种心态。而自信绝对是那种你可以装出来的东西，但最近这些想法对我来说真的死灰复燃了。我发现自己全神贯注于，而且有点不断地在思考美、思考我是否有吸引力、思考人们怎么看我，以及我外表上的一切错误之处。我想分享这种经历，因为它是如此微妙。你知道，这是我生命中第一次在谷歌上搜索整形手术以及我从没想过自己会做的事情，比如该死的下巴缩小手术。
I didn't even know that existed until a few weeks ago. And I know that I would never do it. It's not something I want to do. But there is this like weirdly evil part of my brain that keeps questioning and picking at how I look and wondering whether anyone will ever love me if I look the way I do. And that's just the saddest thought. It makes me so sad. But at the same time, I keep returning to this idea.
直到几周前我都不知道有这东西存在。我知道我永远不会去做。这不是我想做的事。但我的大脑里确实有那么一个诡异邪恶的部分，它一直在质疑和挑剔我的外表，想知道如果我长成这样，是否还会有人爱我。这简直是最悲伤的想法。这让我感到非常难过。但与此同时，我又不断回到这个想法中，
that what I look like is the only thing that people will find appealing about me. And I need to fix something about my appearance to feel at peace and to find someone. And that thought also makes me feel so guilty. I think in this world where we're experiencing increasingly, you know, body positive and accepting and diverse beauty standards, I feel guilty. Like, why do I care about this? I know I'm so much more than my looks.
认为我的长相是别人觉得我有吸引力的唯一原因。为了感到平静并找到某人，我需要修复我外表的某些方面。这种想法也让我感到非常内疚。我认为在这个世界上，我们的身体正经历着日益包容、接纳和多元化的审美标准，我感到很内疚。就像，我为什么要在乎这个？我知道我远不止我的外表。
I have so many positive qualities that matter so much more that's part of me. And I always try and adopt this narrative on this podcast that our inner thoughts and ourselves are what is most valuable. So there's this element of feeling hypocritical and frustrated and angry. And that's hard to admit and really vulnerable. But I want to be honest and transparent. You know, life isn't perfect. And I guess neither am I. And it's complicated and it's making me feel so conflicted. So today we're going to talk about it. We're going to discuss and explore feeling ugly and the beauty standards that are imposed on us. What is the psychology behind obsessing over our attractiveness and our appearance and feeling like you don't meet some standard or some convention? How does that
我有很多更重要的积极品质，那才是我的一部分，对我很重要。我总是试图在这个播客中采纳这样一种叙事：我们内心的想法和我们自己才是最有价值的。所以这里有一种虚伪、沮丧和愤怒的感觉。这很难承认，而且真的很脆弱。但我想要诚实和透明。你知道，生活并不完美。我想我也不完美。这很复杂，让我感到非常矛盾。所以今天我们要谈谈这个。我们将讨论和探索对丑陋的感受以及强加给我们的审美标准。痴迷于我们的吸引力、外表以及觉得自己不符合某种标准或某种习俗背后的心理是什么？这如何
impact our emotional well-being? And what are the psychological origins from things like low self-esteem and body dysmorphia, social comparison, negative learning experiences and all of these societal influences. But I also want to use this time to counter some of the negative beliefs I've been having about myself and maybe some that you're having as well. I think together we're really going to dive into some of the scientific and psychological ways we can overcome these feelings by challenging negative thoughts, by shifting our focus, practicing self-compassion, and limiting our exposure to unrealistic beauty standards to kind of arm ourselves with the best possible mental tools to feel good about our bodies, to feel good about our looks.
影响我们的情感健康？低自尊、体象障碍、社会比较、消极学习经历以及所有这些社会影响等事物的心理根源是什么？但我也想利用这段时间来反击我对自己产生的一些消极信念，也许还有你可能也有的一些消极信念。我认为我们真的会一起深入探讨一些科学和心理学的方法，通过挑战消极思维、转变焦点、练习自我同情以及限制接触不切实际的审美标准来克服这些感受，以此用最好的心理工具武装自己，对自己的身体感到满意，对自己的外表感到满意。
You know, today's going to be a vulnerable episode. I feel like the title gives it away, but I hope we're all prepared. I hope that it really reaches someone out. there who might need to hear it and that people are kind and that you're in the right place to listen to it so without further ado I think we get into it feeling ugly is such a consuming experience and it creates such a narrow view of the world everything becomes about appearances and we tend to become kind of hyper-focused on what we think other people notice about us and how that will reflect our character and their acceptance of us as well. You know, you carry yourself differently.
你知道，今天将会是一个脆弱的节目。我觉得标题已经泄露了，但我希望我们都做好了准备。我希望它真的能触动到某个可能需要听到它的人，希望大家能保持善意，希望你处在收听它的正确状态，所以废话不多说，我想我们这就开始吧。觉得自己丑是一种非常消耗精力的体验，它会让人对世界的看法变得如此狭隘，一切都围绕着外表打转，我们往往会变得过分关注我们认为其他人对我们的看法，以及这会如何反映我们的性格和他们对我们的认可。你知道，你的仪态都会变得不同。
Every outfit seems to exacerbate some floor. You stop going out and spending time doing things that you love. You kind of do a double take of everyone you see on the street and look at them through a new lens. Like, why don't I dress like that? I wish I looked like them. And it's this weird social comparison that never seems to switch off. And it's exhausting. It's so exhausting.
每一套衣服似乎都在放大某种缺陷。你停止外出，不再花时间做你喜欢的事情。你开始对街上看到的每个人都多看两眼，并通过一个新的镜头审视他们。比如，我为什么不那样穿？我希望我长得像他们那样。这是一种奇怪的社会比较，似乎永远不会关闭。而且这太累人了。太累人了。
That's been my experience recently. And it actually has a name. I didn't know this until I started looking into it. But it's called the spotlight effect. It's this mental phenomena whereby we overestimate how much other people notice us and think about us. We can sometimes feel like there's constantly this spotlight on us and all of our imperfections. And they're so noticeable. and everyone notices the things that we notice and the things that we hate about ourselves.
这就是我最近的经历。它实际上有一个名字。在我开始研究之前我并不知道。但这被称为聚光灯效应。这是一种心理现象，即我们高估了别人注意到我们并想到我们的程度。有时我们会觉得好像一直有一束聚光灯照在我们身上和我们所有的不完美上。它们是如此明显，
And this is also very much linked to something called the false consensus effect in psychology, which is our tendency to feel like our personal beliefs are also held by others. So if we feel unattractive and we appraise ourselves as being ugly, other people must believe that as well. I think feeling ugly is interesting when we examine it this way because we, realized that this feeling would kind of be entirely eliminated if we never had to encounter the presence of others or if we as humans were built not to care about what other people thought of us and about their evaluations. But that's kind of not the way that the world works. We've evolved from generations and generations to feel like that spotlight matters.
每个人都注意到了我们所注意到的事情，以及我们所痛恨的关于我们自己的事情。这在心理学上也与所谓的虚假共识效应非常相关，也就是我们倾向于觉得我们的个人信念也被其他人所持有。因此，如果我们觉得自己没有吸引力，并把自己评估为丑陋，其他人也一定这么认为。我认为当我们这样审视时，觉得自己丑是很有趣的，因为我们意识到，如果我们永远不必遇到其他人的存在，或者如果我们作为人类生来就不在乎别人对我们的看法和对我们的评价，这种感觉就会彻底消失。但世界并不是那样运作的。我们经过了一代又一代的进化，才会觉得那束聚光灯很重要，
that what we do and what we look like is the most important thing about us, because at a time, it kind of was. Beauty was a factor that was correlated to survival, especially if you were a woman, evolutionary psychology and this kind of discipline. It kind of theorizes and proposes that men and women have different adaptive strategies and perspectives on beauty. because of this practice of mate selection, right? So some studies have suggested that women may be more attentive to their physical attractiveness and how that will attract a mate because what they look like, things like if their skin is clear and their hair is shiny and they have that body type,
觉得我们的所作所为和外表是我们身上最重要的事情，因为在过去，某种程度上确实如此。美是与生存相关的一个因素，特别是如果你是一个女性的话，进化心理学和这种学科。它在某种程度上进行理论化并提出，由于这种伴侣选择的做法，男女有着不同的适应策略和对美的观点，对吧？因此，一些研究表明，女性可能更关注自己的身体吸引力以及这将如何吸引伴侣，因为她们的长相，比如她们的皮肤是否光滑、头发是否有光泽、她们拥有那种体型，
it signals fertility and genetic fitness. And it used to be purely about survival. You know, if you were beautiful, I guess, or attractive, it showed that you were a good potential mate, therefore you'd be selected, therefore you would be protected and more likely to survive. But as those assumptions and innate assessments have developed and as we have a species have matured and become more civilized, those kind of beauty standards that we typically associate with body image issues and feeling unattractive have kind of. emerged and as women in particular, but also men, I think we're told that if we don't conform to certain standards of attractiveness, a man is never going to choose us. And back when our quality of life was tied to marriage, that really mattered a lot. There's all this gender socialization that occurs from a young age in which we receive a lot of messages about our appearance and our
它暗示了生育能力和基因健康。过去这纯粹是为了生存。你知道，如果你很漂亮，我猜，或者很有吸引力，这表明你是一个潜在的好伴侣，因此你会被选中，因此你会受到保护，更有可能生存下来。但随着这些假设和先天评估的发展，以及我们作为一个物种走向成熟和文明，那些我们通常与体象问题和觉得自己缺乏吸引力联系在一起的审美标准在某种程度上浮现出来了。特别是作为女性，但我也认为男性也被告知，如果我们不符合某些吸引力的标准，男人就永远不会选择我们。而在我们生活质量与婚姻挂钩的过去，这确实非常重要。存在着所有这些从小就开始的性别社会化，我们在其中收到了很多关于我们外表和
attractiveness, especially if you're a woman compared to men. And that socialization process really reinforces the idea that my value as a woman lies in my physical appearance. And I think that's a main contributor to why I've been feeling this way recently. I've kind of woken up to this really sad reality and this evolutionary reality about what my value is to society. And I think a lot of that has contributed to how I've been feeling amongst some other psychological factors that I'm going to discuss in just a second. I think it's hard for me to also ignore the correlation between feeling like I'm ugly and dating again. You know, I've spent the past like better half of the year really focused on myself and now it's like I'm back to seeking male approval and this has
吸引力的信息，尤其是如果你是女性的话，与男性相比。这种社会化过程真正巩固了这样一个观念：我作为女性的价值在于我的外表。我认为这是我最近为什么会有这种感觉的主要原因之一。我某种程度上清醒地认识到了这个非常悲伤的现实，以及关于我对社会的价值的进化现实。我认为除了我马上要讨论的一些其他心理因素之外，很大程度上正是这些导致了我目前的感受。我认为我也很难忽视我觉得自己丑和重新开始约会之间的相关性。你知道，过去大半年我真的把精力都集中在自己身上，而现在感觉就像我回到了寻求男性认可的状态，这
triggered all of these societally ingrained beliefs about my inherent attractiveness and my worth that I've kind of had since a child. It takes a lot of effort and energy to not care about what we look like, especially in a society that puts it front and center. So I think that's one factor, putting myself back into an environment in which first impressions and looks feel like they matter. but also weirdly, if you follow me on Instagram, you'll see that I've started to film some of my episodes, which, you know, I've never done before. This podcast has always been such a solitary in my bedroom or my home kind of exercise. And I think that having to look at myself on video and acknowledge that other people are going to
引发了所有这些我从小就有的、社会根深蒂固的关于我固有的吸引力和我的价值的信念。要做到不在乎我们的外表需要付出大量的努力和精力，尤其是在一个把外表放在最前沿和中心的社会里。所以我认为这是一个因素，把自己重新置于一个感觉第一印象和外表很重要的环境中。但也很奇怪，如果你关注我的Instagram，你会发现我开始拍摄我的一些节目了，你知道，我以前从没这么做过。这个播客一直是一个在我的卧室或家里进行的非常孤独的锻炼。并且我认为不得不看着视频中的自己，并承认其他人会
watch that and perhaps judge me has been really anxiety-inducing and brought a a whole new element to what used to be and still is for me a very personal process where my looks have never mattered, only the content of my brain and what I choose to share verbally. I think it's important to note here that from a psychological perspective, feeling ugly is a subjective experience. And you know, when we talk about ugly, that means a different thing for each different person. It's all very much self-ful. evolved but also societally ingrained. And what we choose to pick it ourselves about and what we choose to hate is very much tied to self-perception. And it's highly subjective, but there's also all of
观看并可能会评判我，这真的让人非常焦虑，并为一个曾经是、对我来说现在依然是一个非常私人的过程引入了一个全新要素。在这个过程中，我的外表从来都不重要，重要的只有我的大脑内容以及我选择用言语分享的东西。我认为在这里值得指出的是，从心理学的角度来看，觉得自己丑是一种主观体验。你知道，当我们谈论丑陋时，对每个人来说这意味着不同的东西。这很大程度上是自我激发的，但也是社会根深蒂固的。我们选择对自己挑剔什么，我们选择痛恨什么，这与自我认知紧密相连。这高度主观，但也有来自我们的文化背景、社会环境和社会的
these strong signals from our cultural background and our societal context and society about what we should look like, about what's beautiful and what standards and features make us worthwhile. And you know, the hardest part about that is that it changes from just. generation to generation, even from like year to year and we can kind of never keep up. And I hate that so much in a way that I can't even begin to kind of form the words to explain because it's just so insidious. And I find myself in like this spiral and then all I can think about is like my younger sisters and how they'll have to face this as well if they're not already. And I also just feel so much self-pity and anger that some of my best years,
所有这些强烈信号，关于我们应该长成什么样，关于什么是美，以及什么标准和特征让我们变得有价值。你知道，其中最难的部分在于它代代相传地在改变，甚至从一年到头都在变，我们似乎永远无法跟上。我非常讨厌这种感觉，甚至无法用言语来解释，因为它是如此隐蔽。我发现自己陷入了一种螺旋式的状态，然后我能想到的只有我的小妹妹们，如果她们还没经历这些的话，她们以后也将不得不面对这一切。而且对于我最好的岁月中的一部分，我感到非常自责和愤怒，
and the best moments of my 20s have been consumed about anxiety, about what I look like. It's like, it's a fucking epidemic. And I think a huge contributor is social comparison that is brought on by more frequent exposure to negative and unrealistic media. I think constant exposure to carefully curated images of beauty can lead to comparison. And if you feel like you don't measure up to these idealized standards, it negatively impacts your self-esteem. This, I think, is particularly the case when we engage in upward social comparison.
二十几岁最好的时光都被对长相的焦虑给消耗掉了。这简直就像是一场该死的流行病。我认为一个巨大的促成因素是由更频繁地接触负面和不切实际的媒体所引发的社会比较。我认为不断接触精心策划的美丽图像会导致比较。如果你觉得自己达不到这些理想化的标准，它就会对你的自尊产生负面影响。我认为，当我们进行向上社会比较时，尤其如此。
And this occurs whereby we select individuals we see as superior in some domain, such as attractiveness, and we compare ourselves. And that's not hard to do when we have millions of incredibly beautiful people that we can look at from our phones. You know, we can go on social media and instantly almost trigger the part of our brain that is going to make us feel bad about our appearance. It's so prolific. It's so easily acceptable and we don't even realize it. And this is what leads to negative self-evaluations, lower self-esteem and feeling kind of ugly. When the comparison that we're
这种情况发生在：我们选择那些我们在某些领域（例如吸引力）认为更优越的个人，并将自己与他们进行比较。当我们手机里有数百万极其美丽的人供我们观看时，要做到这一点并不难。你知道，我们可以刷社交媒体，几乎瞬间就能触发大脑中那个会让我们对自己的外表感到糟糕的部分。它是如此多产。它是如此轻易地被接受，而我们甚至没有意识到这一点。这就是导致负面自我评估、自尊心下降和觉得自己丑的原因。当我们进行的比较
undertaking reveals some kind of deficit in our appearance, that is what triggers this feeling of ugliness or this feeling of dissatisfaction in our physical appearance. And this also kind of links very heavily to self-objectification theory. And this was first presented back in like the 90s, but I've seen such a huge rise in this theory and the popularity of this theory with the normalization and proliferation of social media. So essentially this theory, self-objectification theory suggests that when we are repeatedly exposed to certain beauty standards through readily accessible stimuli and content such as social media, we come to internalize these standards and view ourselves as objects to be evaluated based on appearance as we have implicitly been doing
揭示了我们外表上的某种缺陷时，正是这一点引发了这种丑陋感或对我们外表的不满感。这在很大程度上也与自我客体化理论有关。该理论最早在90年代提出，但我看到随着社交媒体的规范化和激增，这一理论及其受欢迎程度有了巨大的上升。所以本质上，这个理论，即自我客体化理论表明，当我们通过随时随地可获取的刺激和内容（如社交媒体）反复接触某些审美标准时，我们就会内化这些标准，并将自己视为需要根据外表进行评估的对象，就像我们在网上对看到的人进行的那样。
to those we see online. So essentially it's the internalization of the belief that we are being judged based on our bodies and our appearances because that's what we're doing to other people. And this is exacerbated by the online environment created by social media, whereby platforms like Instagram place a strong emphasis on appearance through features like likes and comments, which give us a dopamine hit. It gives us instant gratification to feel like we're receiving that gratification and validation about our bodies and our appearance from people online. And we feel like because we are somewhat evaluating and monitoring and liking and congratulating others on their appearance through these beings, that others must be doing that for us.
所以本质上，它内化了这样一种信念：我们正在根据我们的身体和外表受到评判，因为这就是我们对其他人做的事情。由社交媒体所创造的网络环境加剧了这一点，像Instagram这样的平台通过点赞和评论等功能极大地强调了外表，这些功能给我们带来了多巴胺冲击。这给我们带来了即时满足感，让我们觉得我们正从网民那里获得关于我们身体和外表的这种满足感和认可。而且我们觉得，因为我们通过这些存在在某种程度上评估、监控、点赞和祝贺他人的外表，其他人也一定在为我们这样做。
Hence, this spotlight effect comes back into play here. This self-objectification is what can cause us to be more susceptible to social comparison and to negative self-perceptions regarding appearance. and you know we haven't even spoken yet about the rise in things like face tune and editing and let me tell you that everyone is doing it everyone because in a world where we feel like our lives have to be perfectly curated and we need to look a certain way it's kind of hard to not fall into the trap of smoothing out and imperfection and editing our faces and our bodies because that's what we've been told matters. That's been my experience. And I see a massive
因此，聚光灯效应在这里再次发挥作用。这种自我客体化正是导致我们更容易受到社会比较以及关于外表的负面自我认知影响的原因。你知道，我们甚至还没有谈论过美图秀秀和修图等事物的兴起，让我告诉你，每个人都在这么做，每一个人，因为在一个我们觉得生活必须完美策划、我们需要看起来特定模样的世界里，要不陷入抚平不完美以及修饰我们的脸和身材的陷阱是很难的，因为那是我们被告知重要的事情。这就是我的经历。我看到我的社交媒体使用与
correlation between my use of social media and these feelings of ugliness that I've been experiencing. And I think if you're already going through a period of low self-esteem, all of these influences can become so cumulative. You know, our self-esteem, it refers to this overall subjective evaluation and perception of our worth, of our value, of our competence, and it encompasses how we see ourselves, our beliefs about our abilities, our attractiveness even, and the extent to which we accept and respect ourselves and see our position in the world as valuable. And the origins of our self-esteem can be traced back to various factors that shape our sense of self-worth from very early on in our lives. You know, our primary influence is early experiences and interactions,
我一直在经历的这些丑陋感之间存在着巨大的相关性。而且我认为如果你已经经历了一段自尊心低下的时期，所有这些影响就会变得如此累积。你知道，我们的自尊，指的是对我们的价值、我们的价值、我们的能力的总体的、主观的评估和认知，它包含我们如何看待自己、我们对自己能力的信念、甚至我们的吸引力，以及我们在多大程度上接受和尊重自己，并将我们在世界上的地位视为有价值的。我们自尊的根源可以追溯到在我们生命早期塑造我们自我价值感的各种因素。你知道，我们主要的influences是早期的经历和互动，
particularly in childhood. The way we were treated and loved and nurtured, not just by our caregivers, but also by people like our teachers or our peers, is going to significantly impact the self-esteem we have as adults. If you received positive and affirming experience, if you were treated well if you weren't bullied, I guess, that's going to foster a healthy sense of self-worth, especially when your value is reinforced by your parents. But conversely, negative experiences such as criticism, such as bullying, comments about looks, rejection,
特别是在童年时期。我们被对待、被爱和被培养的方式，不仅来自于我们的照顾者，也来自于我们的老师或同龄人等，将显着影响我们作为成年人所拥有的自尊。如果你得到了积极和肯定的经历，如果你受到了很好的对待，如果你没有被欺凌，我想，那将培养出健康的自我价值感，尤其是当你的价值得到父母的强化时。但相反，负面的经历，例如批评、欺凌、对外表的评论、拒绝，
even neglect, that can undermine our self-esteem and lead to these feelings of inadequacy being a much larger part of our lives, the older we get. I think over time, our self-esteem becomes ingrained. It's no longer what other people think or what other people say. We become our kind of own worst enemy and our own evil voice in our head, telling ourselves that we don't matter, that we're unattractive. And when we have low self-esteem, that's where a lot of these negative beliefs about our appearance can
甚至忽视，都会损害我们的自尊，并导致随着我们年龄的增长，这些无能感成为我们生活中更大的一部分。我认为随着时间的推移，我们的自尊已经根深蒂固。这不再是别人怎么想或别人怎么说的问题。我们成了我们自己最糟糕的敌人，成了我们脑海中那个邪恶的声音，告诉自己我们不重要，我们没有吸引力。而当我们自尊心低下时，许多关于我们外表的负面信念就是从这里
come from because we focus on our flaws. We focus on our shortcomings and what that results in is self-criticism, self-doubt and feeling ugly, feeling unattractive. I think this is interesting to me because I've always felt like I've had a fairly positive self-esteem until recently, so I'm still trying to figure out what's changed. And I guess another explanation that we just have to discuss here that we can't ignore are certain psychological disorders that are linked to increased feelings of unattractiveness or an obsession with our appearance. And I think the one that is most valuable and appropriate to discuss here is body dysmorphic disorder. Body dysmorphia is another name for it and essentially it is a psychological disorder.
产生出来的，因为我们专注于自己的缺陷。我们专注于我们的缺点，而这导致的结果就是自我批评、自我怀疑和觉得自己丑，觉得没有吸引力。我觉得这很有趣，因为我一直觉得自己的自尊心相当积极，直到最近，所以我还在努力找出是什么改变了。我想我们在这里不得不讨论的另一个不可忽视的解释是，某些心理障碍与不断增加的不吸引力感或对外表的痴迷有关。我认为最值得且最适合在这里讨论的是体相障碍。体象障碍是它的另一个名字，本质上它是一种心理障碍。
It's characterized by an obsessive preoccupation with our perceived flaws. And it often leads to distress and impairment in our daily functioning because we are so caught up in these small things that we see as imperfect. So we avoid certain activities. We enter into a negative thought spiral. We feel anxious. And people with body dysmorphic disorder, they often have a distorted perception of their appearance, meaning not objective. We focus excessively on minor or imagined defects, and I think it impacts everyone.
其特征是对我们察觉到的缺陷有强迫性的专注。并且它经常导致日常功能中的痛苦和受损，因为我们太纠结于这些我们认为不完美的微小事情了。所以我们回避某些活动。我们陷入了消极思维的螺旋。我们感到焦虑。患有体象障碍的人，通常对自己的外表有着扭曲的认知，这意味着这不是客观的。我们过度关注微小的或想象出来的缺陷，我认为这会影响到每个人。
I think any mental disorder or condition like this is not just reserved for a certain group of people. You know, you could be the most beautiful person in the world and still have body dysmorphia because it is entirely subjective and based on your own self-appraisal. And there are so many key features of this disorder that explain why sometimes we just feel gross and ugly without any explanation or justification. Some say that this condition is genetic, that it comes from social influences, that it comes from parents, it comes from caregivers, it comes from even OCD, it's super chromobid, but I think it is a really complex psychological condition that really explains why sometimes nothing can appear wrong from the outside. Everything can look perfect, right? You can be so conventionally attractive, but there
我认为任何像这样的精神障碍或病情都不限于某一群人。你知道，你可能是世界上最漂亮的人，却依然患有体象障碍，因为它是完全主观的，并且基于你自己的自我评估。这种疾病有许多关键特征，解释了为什么有时我们没有任何解释或理由就会觉得自己又脏又丑。有人说这种情况是基因决定的，它来自社会影响，它来自父母，它来自照顾者，它甚至来自强迫症，它是超共病的，但我认为这是一个非常复杂的心理状况，真正解释了为什么有时从外表上看什么问题都没有。一切看起来都完美，对吧？你可以拥有传统的吸引力，但
is just this obsession with how we look. And it shows up in things like, you know, needing constant reassurance, never feeling good enough, always believing that. that people find us unattractive, always being able to identify some flaw, checking mirrors all the time, trying to conceal ourselves and hide away. And I just think that it's something that needs to be considered in this broader experience of feeling constantly unattractive and feeling like your appearance and your perception of your appearance is holding you back in your life. and importantly, you know, I think this information, it's not really a guide for self-diagnosis. It's just a possible explanation.
就是有一种对外表的痴迷。它表现在诸如，你知道，需要不断的保证、感觉永远不够好、总是相信别人觉得我们没有吸引力、总是能够找出某种缺陷、一直照镜子、试图隐藏自己并躲藏起来。我只是觉得，在持续感到没有吸引力以及觉得自己的外表和对自我外表的认知阻碍了生活的更广泛体验中，这是需要被考虑的事情。而且重要的是，你知道，我认为这些信息并不是自我诊断的指南。这只是一种可能的解释。
And if you can relate to this explanation, it is really important to seek a professional diagnosis because it can get you into the treatment and the therapy that you may need. And this is just such a nuanced space and there are a million contributing factors and reasons that we tend to feel this way, but regardless of these psychological explanations, like, let's be real. It just, it really sucks to feel this way. It kind of casts a shadow over our whole lives and can become such an obsession. It just weighs everything down. It just makes everything feel distorted. And like, if you feel ugly, the world feels ugly. And that's really no way to live our lives, kind of stripped of enjoyment and, you know, obsessed with whether our chin looks
如果你能与这种解释产生共鸣，寻求专业诊断真的很重要，因为这可以让你接受你可能需要的治疗和疗法。这只是一个如此微妙的领域，有成百上千的促成因素和原因导致我们倾向于这样感受，但不管这些心理解释如何，说实话。这种感觉真的很糟糕。它在我们的整个生活中投下了阴影，并可能成为一种痴迷。它让一切都变得沉重。它让一切都感觉扭曲了。就像，如果你觉得自己丑，世界就会感觉很丑。这真的不是一种生活方式，剥夺了乐趣，（你知道的）痴迷于我们的下巴在那张照片里看起来
too big in that photo or whether our lives would be better if we lost weight. You know, I know that on an intimate level and amongst all of my feelings of frustration and anxiety and just general apathy for life at the moment, I also just want to have agency over how I feel. I don't like feeling trapped by my thoughts. So I kind of want to move on and I really want to be free of some of these worries and these anxieties and these thoughts. So how do we kind of counter and overcome feeling ugly? I think I'm providing these strategies very much for you, but also for myself, to kind of remind me that there is freedom from these thoughts and there is freedom from these feelings. And hopefully we can kind of share and talk through.
是不是太大，或者如果我们减肥生活会不会更好。你知道，我在亲密层面上以及在所有沮丧、焦虑和目前对生活普遍冷漠的情绪中，我也只想对自己的感受拥有自主权。我不喜欢被自己的思绪所困。所以我有点想继续前进，我真的很想摆脱一些这样的担忧、焦虑和想法。那么我们该如何对抗和克服觉得自己丑呢？我想我提供这些策略很大程度上是为了你们，但也是为了我自己，为了提醒自己，我们可以从这些想法和感受中解脱出来。希望我们能一起分享和讨论
some of the strategies that I've been adopting recently to take time for self-reflection and reinforce my inherent belief that looks do not determine my worth. It can be really hard to believe sometimes, especially when other parts of our minds are kind of self-sabotaging us, but it's not impossible. So if you're kind of on a self-love journey like I obviously am at the moment, we're going to talk tangible strategies for shutting down the nasty parts of our brain that trying to tell us our appearance is all that matters. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
我最近采用的一些策略，用来花时间进行自我反思并强化我固有的信念：外表并不能决定我的价值。有时这很难相信，特别是当我们的心灵的其他部分在进行自我破坏时，但这并非不可能。所以如果你像我目前显然一样正处于自爱之旅中，我们将讨论具体的策略，来关闭我们大脑中那些试图告诉我们外表才是一切的讨厌部分。《2%》。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中坚韧精神、健身以及培养心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。
That's T-W-O-P-P-Sent on the I. I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
也就是T-W-O-P-P-Sent，在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont His, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英格利西。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希斯的节目，畅谈80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，1984年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的话题，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，
Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing, and we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,
基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们，已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在追逐它，并且不知道我们什么时候已经做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·布恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法院听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的不一致之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭诉讼的序幕，
to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Lens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of Internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
以证明真相。埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。这需要一大批网络侦探来破案。我想让人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as,
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，
Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Here's the thing I keep repeating to myself as kind of a self-soothing reminder. Appearance doesn't matter as much as society often makes it seem. And no one is looking at you as closely as you are looking and examining yourself. Ask yourself this question. How often do you look at someone and pick apart their every floor? How often do you think about how someone isn't attractive or how they don't
劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这还没结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是我不断对自己重复的一件事，作为一种自我安慰的提醒：外表并不像社会通常表现得那么重要。没有人像你审视和检查自己那样仔细地看着你。问自己这个问题。你多久会看某人一眼并挑剔他们的每一个缺陷？你多久会想某人如何没有吸引力或者他们如何不
look good? And how often do you think about that for like hours of the day? Like I would say we never do that. I never do that at least. So why do we think that people are doing the same for us? Why do we think that people are spending so much time in their day worrying or appraising us as unattractive. And if that even is the case, if there are people out there whose entire purpose in life is just to think about how we don't look good enough for them, does their opinion even really matter? Do we really want to be around those people? You know, those people aren't doing that. There are very few people in the world who are choosing to make that decision in their life to
看起来不错？你一天里有多少个小时会去想这个？比如我会说我们从来不会那样。至少我从来不会。那么为什么我们觉得别人会对我们做同样的事呢？为什么我们觉得人们会花那么多时间在担忧或评价我们不够有吸引力上？即使真是这样，如果真有人把人生全部的意义都用来琢磨我们配不上他们的审美，那他们的意见真的重要吗？我们真的想和这样的人待在一起吗？你知道，那些人根本不会这么做。世界上极少有人会在生活中做出那种选择，
to feel that way about others. And I think it's a common but important reminder that your true beauty really lies beyond physical appearance. And it's rooted in the qualities that make you unique. Your worth and value as a human being should not be determined solely by how you look. It is literally the least important thing about you. Your body is a vessel. That's what I keep saying. My body is just a vessel for my character, for my kindness, for my empathy, for my actions. And those are what truly define me, my inequalities, my passions, my talents, the way that I treat others. I always think of this quote from, what's that children's book? I think it's called The Twits or I don't know what it's called.
去对别人抱有那种看法。我认为这是一个常见但重要的提醒：真正的美实际上超越了外表。它根植于那些让你独一无二的品质之中。作为一个人，你的价值和意义不应仅仅由你的外表来决定。这绝对是你身上最不重要的东西。你的身体只是一艘船。我一直这么说。我的身体只是承载我性格、善良、同理心和行动的一艘船。而这些才是真正定义我的东西——我的品质、我的热情、我的才华以及我对待他人方方式。我总是想起一句名言，出自哪本童书来着？我想好像叫《蠢特夫妇》，或者我不知道它叫什么。
It's like a roll-dahl book or something. And there's this quote though that really stands out that a person who, who has good thoughts can never be ugly because if you have good thoughts, they will always kind of shine out of your face like some beams and you will always look lovely. And I firmly believe this. I know there's probably not much of like a psychological evidence base for this, but I really do believe that when you have a positive outlook and you treat others well and you think good things, that really shows up in how you behave and it shows up in. how you carry yourself and it immediately makes you more attractive.
好像是罗尔德·达尔的书之类的。其中有一句话真的很深刻：一个拥有美好思想的人永远不会丑陋，因为如果你有美好的想法，它们就会像光芒一样从你的脸上散发出来，让你看起来总是那么可爱。我坚信这一点。我知道这可能没有什么心理学依据，但我真的坚信，当你拥有积极的心态、善待他人并且心怀善意时，这确实会体现在你的举止中，体现在你展现自我的方式中，并会立刻让你变得更有吸引力。
But I guess what are some of the ways we can reinforce this from a psychological perspective? It really doesn't matter what you look like. If you feel unattractive, that's really all that matters. That's really what's going to impact your life and kind of ruin your day. So we need to find a way to overcome that. I think firstly, one of the biggest things is to challenge those negative thoughts. become aware of those negative appraisals about your appearance and challenge them with more realistic and positive beliefs. When you find those kind of feelings creeping in like,
但我想，从心理学的角度来看，有哪些方法可以强化这一点呢？无论你长什么样，这其实都不重要。如果你觉得自己没有吸引力，那才是最重要的事情。那才是真正会影响你的生活并毁掉你一天心情的关键。所以我们需要找到克服这一点的方法。我认为首先，最重要的事情之一就是挑战那些负面想法。去察觉那些关于你外表的负面评价，并用更现实、更积极的信念去挑战它们。当你发现这种情绪悄然滋生时，比如：
I wish I was thinner, my paws are so huge, I hate how I look, remind yourself instead and replace those beliefs with your positive qualities, with your achievements and the things you like about yourself beyond physical appearance. For everything that you can say you hate about the way you look, for everything that you find wrong, for every floor, list something positive about your character. I think shift your attention away from appearance
我希望自己能再瘦一点，我的毛孔太大了，我讨厌自己的长相。这时要提醒自己，用你的积极品质、你的成就以及除了外表之外你喜欢自己的地方来替代这些信念。对于你所讨厌的外表上的每一处，对于你发现的所有不对劲的地方，对于每一个缺点，都列举出一个你性格中的积极方面。我认为应该把你的注意力从外表上转移开，
and place more value on your inequalities. And part of that is also developing skills and pursuing passions and engaging in activities that cultivate a sense of self-worth that is based on your character and accomplishments rather than something that's super fleeting and unimportant, like, appearance. I think you also need to question the evidence for these thoughts. That's something that I've been really trying to do.
更加重视你的内在品质。其中的一部分还包括培养技能、追求爱好以及参与能够培养自我价值感的活动，这种自我价值感应该建立在你的性格和成就之上，而不是建立在像外表这样转瞬即逝且无足轻重的事情上。我认为你还需要质疑这些想法背后的证据。这也是我一直在努力去做的事情。
Like, this idea that I'm ugly, this, like, a compulsion that I have at the moment, are, you know, is that really based on objective facts? Or is it a subjective perception? I think often our negative thoughts about appearance, are distorted and they're not supported by objective reality. Like, has anyone ever said those things to you? Has anyone ever really picked up on those small features and factors about yourself that you don't like?
比如“我很丑”这个想法，或者我目前产生的这种强迫观念，你知道，这真的是基于客观事实吗？还是只是一种主观感知？我认为我们对自身外表的负面想法往往是被扭曲的，并不受客观现实的支持。比如，有人对你说过这样的话吗？真的有人挑出过那些你不喜欢的、关于你自己的微小特征和因素吗？
How often have they actually said something? And if they have said something, do you really care about their opinion? Have you ever looked at your friend and loved them less because of some feature they don't like about themselves? have you ever discredited someone's opinion because of their appearance? And why is that? Was there a valid reason behind you doing that? I think we need to challenge the validity of these thoughts and consider some alternative rational perspectives. You know, that's easier said than done. You know, I'm coming at you right now saying that even I can't do this. Like I'm giving,
他们到底说过多少次？如果他们说过，你真的在乎他们的意见吗？你有没有因为某个朋友身上有他们自己不喜欢的外表特征而减少对他们的爱？你有没有因为某人的外表而否定他们的观点？为什么会这样？你这么做背后有什么合理的理由吗？我认为我们需要挑战这些想法的合理性，并考虑一些替代性的理性观点。你知道，说起来容易做起来难。我现在就是在对你们说，甚至连我自己都做不到这一点。就像我正在给出，
really hearing advice from someone who probably needs to take their own advice. But I think it's just something to really think about and something that I need to put in place in my own life as well. And that's where the second tip comes in, which is to practice self-compassion. We're not always going to be good at countering our negative thoughts and beliefs. Sometimes they are still going to be there and they're still going to exist, no matter how much positive thinking and attitude work we do. So treat yourself with kindness and compassion. Instead of being overly critical, practice self-executive.
听取那些可能自己也需要这些建议的人的意见。但我认为这确实是值得深思的事情，也是我需要在自己的生活中去实践的事情。这就引出了第二个技巧，那就是练习自我同情。我们不可能总是擅长对抗我们的负面想法和信念。有时它们仍然会存在，无论我们做多少积极思考和心态建设的工作。所以，要以善良和同情心对待自己。不要过度苛求，而是要实践自我慈悲。
Treat yourself as you would treat a friend. Or even better, treat yourself as you would treat the childhood version of you. If you wouldn't say the things you're saying about your body or your appearance to the child version of you to your inner child, why are you saying them to the adult version of you? That child is still inside of you. That version of you that is innocent and vulnerable and needs to be protected, they still exist. So protect them. Treating that version of you with kindness means treating yourself with kindness as well.
像对待朋友一样对待自己。或者更好的是，像对待童年时期的自己那样对待自己。如果你不会对童年时期的自己——对你内心的那个小孩——说那些你用来评价自己身体或外表的话，你为什么要对成年的自己说呢？那个孩子依然在你内心深处。那个天真、脆弱、需要保护的你自己，依然存在。所以，去保护他们吧。以善良对待那个时期的自己，也就意味着以善良对待现在的自己。
And I think a part of practicing self-compassion is also treating others with compassion and the respect that we feel we deserve. I think when we do kind things, when we do good by others, we express the best parts of ourselves. And we prove to ourselves that how we treat other people and how we treat other people and how we we make people feel is worth so much more than how we appear physically to others. I think of equal importance here is to surround yourself with positive influences and surround yourself with supportive and positive people who appreciate you for who you are. Avoid those toxic relationships or those toxic environments that reinforce your negative self-perceptions and environments that kind of subconsciously or implicitly forced you to be self-critical,
我认为践行自我同情的一部分，也包括以同情和我们觉得自己应得的尊重去对待他人。我认为当我们做善良的事情、对他人表现出善意时，我们就展现了自己最好的一面。并且我们向自己证明了，我们如何对待他人、我们如何对待别人以及我们如何让别人感到快乐，这比我们在外表上如何呈现给他人要有价值得多。我认为同样重要的是，要让自己置身于积极的影响中，让自己周围都是那些欣赏你本色、支持你且积极的人。远离那些有毒的人际关系或环境，它们会强化你对自己的负面认知，潜移默化地迫使你变得自我批判，
one of those being our online environments. I think an element of this is limiting exposure to harmful beauty standards. Be very mindful of the media and the content that you consume. If someone makes you feel inadequate, you have the agency and the power to unfollow. You get to control your own. and your exposure to the images and the content that is potentially triggering. And you deserve peace and a gentler mind. And part of that is setting boundaries around what you choose to expose yourself to.
其中之一就是我们的网络环境。这其中的一个关键点是限制接触有害的审美标准。要对你所消费的媒体和内容保持高度警惕。如果有人让你觉得自己不够好，你完全有主动权和力量去取消关注。你可以掌控自己，控制自己接触那些可能引发负面情绪的图片和内容。你值得拥有内心的平静和更温柔的心态。而其中的一部分，就是为你所选择接触的事物设定边界。
You know, it sounds really obvious, but I think we don't always realize how much of these kind of beauty standards and these toxic negative beliefs creep into our minds. and our self-perception from mindlessly scrolling and consuming. Someone also said this to me the other day, this kind of fourth tip that I have. And I was like, this is amazing. I need to share this. And I think it's always a good thing to engage in activities that make you feel accomplished or like a good person that have nothing to do with looks. Being good at something or just spending your time cultivating a new hobby or a skill, it takes you away from that negative self-talk. And it diverts that energy into something that builds your self-esteem in a positive direction.
你知道，这听起来可能很显眼，但我觉得我们并不总是意识到，这些审美标准和有毒的负面信念，有多少是通过无意识地刷屏和消费潜入我们的思维和自我认知中的。前几天也有人对我说过这样的话，这是我的第四个建议。当时我觉得：这太棒了，我一定要分享出来。我认为去做那些能让你有成就感或觉得自己是个好人、且与外表无关的活动，总是件好事。擅长某件事，或者只是花时间培养一项新爱好或新技能，能让你远离那些负面的自我对话，并将这股能量引导到朝着积极方向建立自尊的事情上去。
For me, that's, you know, doing this. That's getting to share my thoughts and my feelings and my knowledge on this show. But it's also things like going out into nature or swimming in the ocean, hiking, all that good stuff. And honestly, nature is the best equalizer because she does not care what you look like. She doesn't care if you're conventionally attractive or not. She treats everyone the same. And these activities also take us out of our minds and into the present and allow us to break free of that spiraling that can often accompany critiquing our image and our appearance. And finally, I think it goes without saying, but seek professional support.
对我而言，这就是做这件事。这就是在这个节目中分享我的想法、感受和知识。但这也包括去大自然中走走、在大海中游泳、远足，所有这些美好的事情。老实说，大自然是最伟大的平衡器，因为它根本不在乎你长什么样。它不在乎你是否符合传统审美。它对每个人都一视同仁。这些活动还能把我们的注意力从大脑的胡思乱想中抽离出来，回到当下，让我们摆脱那种常常伴随着批判自己形象和外表的精神内耗。最后，我觉得不言而喻的是，寻求专业支持。
If these negative feelings about your appearance persist and significantly impact your daily life, sometimes we just need someone who's separate from the situation to help us out. And that's something that I'm doing. Like, you know, we are pro therapy on this show. We are so pro therapy. I did a whole episode on your guide to therapy in your 20s. And I think that it's really valuable to speak to someone who has perspective, maybe someone who is older.
如果这些关于外表的负面情绪持续存在，并严重影响了你的日常生活，有时我们只是需要一个置身事外的人来拉我们一把。这也是我正在做的事。就像你知道的，我们这个节目非常支持心理治疗。我们太支持心理治疗了。我专门做过一期关于“二十多岁心理治疗指南”的节目。我认为，与一个有阅历的人、或许是一个年长一些的人交流，真的很有价值。
And especially when it comes to things like a body dysmorphic disorder or something along those lines, you may need a more. clinical explanation and some more guidance around some of the practical and even medical ways that you can really assist your brain in saying goodbye to these fears and these worries and these feelings. Like sometimes you just need a space that's free from judgment to say what I'm saying right now. Like I feel ugly. I feel unattractive and I want to talk about it and I want to kind of release some of that built up stress and energy and frustration and just sadness that I feel like I always have to hold.
尤其是当涉及到像躯体变形障碍或类似的事情时，你可能需要更具临床解释性的说明，以及更多的指导，来了解一些切实的甚至是医疗层面的方法，真正帮助你的大脑向这些恐惧、担忧和情绪说再见。有时候，你只是需要一个免受评判的空间，去说出我现在正在说的话。比如我觉得自己很难看。我觉得自己没有吸引力，我想谈论它，我想释放一些积压的压力、精力和挫折感，以及那些我觉得自己不得不一直背负的悲伤。
So I really want to reinforce this one last time. I'm so sorry, but you're not alone in this. No experience is ever solitary or isolated. You know, maybe my feelings help validate that for you. I really hope so. And I sometimes think that if someone looked at me, I don't think they would know that this is what's been going on in my mind. thoughts are experienced in solitude unless we choose to communicate them and be open with those around us. And yes, I feel ugly. And this is something that has been part of my reality for a little while. So as hard as that is to admit, I don't want to feel that way anymore. And I'm really tired of being so focused and obsessed on my appearance.
所以我真的想最后再次强调这一点。非常抱歉，但在这条路上你并不孤单。没有任何体验是孤立的。你知道，也许我的感受能为你提供一些共鸣。我真的很希望如此。有时我想，如果有人看着我，他们大概不会知道这就是我脑海中一直在发生的事情。除非我们选择交流并向周围人敞开心扉，否则想法往往只在孤独中经历。是的，我觉得自己丑。这已经成为我现实生活中的一部分有一段时间了。所以，尽管承认这一点很难，但我不想再有这种感觉了。我真的厌倦了如此关注和沉迷于自己的外表。
And I know I am so much more than that. And every day I really strive to reinforce that and remind myself of this truth. You know, when I'm 70, I don't want to look back at my 20s and regret how much time I spent worrying about whether other people thought I was beautiful or attractive. I want to know that I treated people well. I want to know that I was kind, that I made a difference, that I enjoyed my life and made incredible memories and didn't care if I was ugly doing it. So I hope that you get to feel that way as well.
我知道我远不止于此。每一天，我都在努力强化这一点，提醒自己这个真理。你知道，当我七十岁的时候，我不希望回首自己的二十多岁时，会后悔自己花了那么多时间去担心别人是否觉得我美丽或有吸引力。我希望我知道自己曾善待他人。我希望我知道自己很善良，自己曾产生过影响，自己享受了生活并留下了美好的回忆，而且根本不在乎自己当时长得是不是难看。所以我希望你也能有这样的感受。
And looking at it holistically enforcing ourselves. into kind of that hindsight mentality can really help. And I also think sharing can help. You'd be surprised how many people in your life are probably feeling the same way. When I was talking about this with my friends and being like, oh, is this too personal? Is this too intimate? They were like, fuck no, I feel this way as well.
从整体来看，强迫自己进入那种事后诸葛亮的心态真的能帮到忙。我也觉得分享会有所帮助。你会惊讶地发现，你生活中有那么多人可能都有同感。当我跟朋友谈起这件事，问他们“这会不会太个人化了？这会不会太私密了？”时，他们说：“去他的，才不会，我也有同感。”
And there's someone out there who's feeling equally this kind of terrible about their body and their appearance. So I hope it's reached you. And I hope you feel better knowing that you're not experiencing this by yourself. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. Kind of a tough one, super vulnerable. So please be kind. I don't want to wake up tomorrow and have people being like, you were entirely correct.
外面肯定也有人对自己的身体和外表感到同样糟糕。所以我希望这段话能传达给你。希望你得知自己并不是独自经历这一切时，能感觉好一些。非常感谢大家收听这一期节目。这一期有点沉重，也非常坦诚，所以请大家口下留情。我可不想明天醒来时，看到有人说：“你完全说对了，
You actually are super fucking ugly. So show your mouth. I don't think anyone would ever say that. But, you know, if you did like this episode and it provided you with some valuable insights, maybe share it on. Leave a five-star review if you feel cool to do so. It really does help the show to grow and reach new people. and it makes my day, makes me feel like I'm doing something valuable.
你其实真的他妈的超级丑。”所以展现你们的口才吧。我想没人会这么说。但是，如果你喜欢这期节目，它为你提供了一些有价值的见解，不妨分享出去。如果你觉得可以的话，留下一个五星好评吧。这真的对节目的成长和触达新听众很有帮助，而且它会让我的一整天都变得美好，让我觉得自己在做有价值的事情。
So if that's something you feel cool to do so, please give it a go. If not, that's all right. You're still welcome here. And I hope to have you back for another episode. If there is something on your mind to do with your 20s, to do with psychology, and you want to know more, please follow me at That Psychology Podcast and shoot me an episode suggestion. I love hearing about what everyone's going through and what your experiences are and how we can kind of apply a scientific and deep psychological knowledge and explanation to it. So hope to see you over
所以如果你觉得可以的话，请试一试吧。如果不行，也没关系。这里随时欢迎你。我希望下一期节目还能见到你。如果你有什么关于二十岁、关于心理学的心事想要了解更多，请在That Psychology Podcast关注我，并给我发一期节目建议。我喜欢听大家正在经历什么、你们的体验是什么，以及我们如何将科学和深度的心理学知识与解释应用到其中。希望能在那里见到你。
there. As always, thank you so much for listening and for supporting the show. And we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts,
一如既往，非常感谢大家的收听和对节目的支持。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》？这就是IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上的TWA%，
or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
或在你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。对于1979年来说，那对我是个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着通过我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家，来弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。那真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人穿着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
网络侦探大军发掘出了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历过同样的事情。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。